I thought if I don't deal with this I
literally am gonna die I need to do
something about it this is the new Tom
Watson a transformation almost beyond
recognition I kept seeing my kids get
older and they're 13 and 10 and I want
to live for them in just over a year he
lost 100 pounds in weight when I first
started to exercise it was utterly you
know overwhelming it was exhausting and
quite humiliating when you jogging
around the park in your 22 stone his
catalysts for change came two years
after being diagnosed in 2015 with type
2 diabetes I remember just feeling shame
and embarrassment really that other than
it had come to that and I but I kind of
put it in a mental drawer and shutting
the door and locked it I didn't want to
think about it so this is my daily cup
of coffee usually I'll skip food for
breakfast and I just have either a
little bit of butter or what they call
MCT oil in my coffee and for me when I
first started doing it it took away the
sugar cravings and this just sort of
gets me through to lunchtime without
being particularly hungry in the morning
Tom's now reversed his diabetes with a
new regime and bulletproof coffee in the
morning healthy eating and above all
zero sugar I describe myself as a
reformed sugar addict and I still think
I'm a sugar addict if I if I eat sugar
now or refined sugar in confectionery
and puddings I just want more I can't I
can't stop on I'm that guy who would eat
the packet of chocolate Hobnobs
you know you'd eat one on that heat the
whole lot I just feel that I managed to
broke break a cycle
when the weights kind of quicker than I
thought
and certainly quicker than my GP thought
was possible as well I checked ketone
level because that is an indication of
whether my body is drawing energy from
fat or glucose but not everyone does
that
there's no calorie counting but Tom does
run cycle and walk to work and he's no
longer classed as obese nobody
recognizes me so I keep getting stopped
to security and answer comments because
they think that I've tommnow wants
remission for all type 2 diabetics his
change has been radical and fast he says
in every way I can say with all candor I
don't think I've ever been as happy it
just feels like the world is full of
more opportunity really and there's so
many benefits that this year is given
that it also means that I feel a lot
more just chill down in life maybe to
children for politics even adult romance
in Sky News